[Music]
hi I'm Patrick and I up customers in
Montreal learn about Google cloud I'm
really excited to see the launch of our
newest region in Montreal this makes us
the 15th GCP region and means better
performance lower latency and more
flexibility for local customers with the
opening of this new region Google cloud
platform products are now offered and
osted from Montreal this new region is
everything that you need to build and
scale our services include compute big
data storage and networking let's check
out the demo so from the main Google
cloud platform dashboard we'll go down
the product list and choose storage from
storage with the option of creating a
new bucket we will create new bucket
we'll call that bucket our first
Canadian bucket we wandered back into be
regional storage because we want the
data to stay within the new Montreal
region we'll scroll down our list of
region and choose North American
northeast one which is the name of the
new montreal-based region or click to
create that new bucket I now have a
bucket hosted within our Montreal region
I just need to choose my file I'll
upload it to the bucket and here we are
we have one file stored in our new
montreal-based region north america
north east one it's as easy as that
we've opened this region in Montreal
because of the rising demand for cloud
services customer research with Ubisoft
geotab in Imagi just seen him a few of
left onto the cloud as part of the
auricular FX initiative research project
video game maker Ubisoft is using Google
Cloud Storage to serve pictures and data
of Egyptian hieroglyphs the use compute
engine in the mail engine to process and
classify that data with the goal of
accelerating our understanding of this
ancient language the new Montreal region
means more speed and availability for
Canadian customers here at Google
we're here to help you scale your
business the Google cloud way come talk
to us
[Music]